Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Questo è un invito a un viaggio.
Un viaggio meraviglioso, nella più alta
cultura accademica internazionale.
Il viaggio è gratuito:
gli unici requisiti sono curiosità
e desiderio di apprendere.
Questo viaggio è possibile
grazie a una rivoluzione,
che ha trasformato radicalmente -
e che nei prossimi anni stravolgerà -
il panorama universitario mondiale.
Questa rivoluzione si chiama MOOC,
un acronimo un po' buffo
che sta per "Massive Open Online Courses":
corsi aperti, in rete,
per grandi numeri di studenti.
Studenti di tutte le età,
di tutti gli interessi
e di tutte le generazioni.
Questa rivoluzione è cominciata
quattro anni fa,
con il lancio del primo MOOC di Stanford
sull'intelligenza artificiale.
160.000 studenti
hanno frequentato questo primo corso
e di là, a valanga,
questo fenomeno si è andato espandendo
a partire da tre grandi
aggregatori americani -
si chiamano Coursera, edX e Udacity -
e poi sono arrivati anche gli altri.
Poi vedremo la risposta
dei francesi, degli inglesi,
e quella nostra degli italiani.
Per darvi una dimensione del fenomeno,
ad oggi abbiamo oltre 40.000.000
di studenti sui corsi MOOC,
più di 4000 corsi universitari.
E tutto questo, naturalmente,
significa molte cose:
significa che le università
possono ancora svolgere, e svolgeranno,
un ruolo importantissimo
solo nella misura in cui
si apriranno sempre di più
alle nuove dinamiche comunicative.
Perché se passiamo
tre quarti della nostra vita -
e i nostri figli e nipoti
non ne parliamo -
sempre di più con questi aggeggi,
è impensabile che lo studio universitario
si continui a fare come 200 anni fa.
E questa è la chiave principale,
un modo di entrare
nelle nuove dinamiche cognitive
delle generazioni digitali.
Però, poi, c'è un altro aspetto
molto importante,
è l'aspetto che ci interessa di più.
La qualità.
I MOOC sono diventati,
così rapidamente, così importanti
perché offrono a tutti il meglio.
Perché i migliori docenti del mondo
insegnano liberamente
per chi abbia voglia di apprendere.
Vedremo, poi, nella seconda parte,
[che] c'è qualche resistenza,
[ve lo] potete immaginare;
c'è qualcuno che vorrebbe
che le cose restassero
come sono sempre state.
Ma la spinta è enorme.
Ed è una spinta che viene dall'Occidente
ma viene anche, come potete immaginare,
dal resto del mondo.
Come si formeranno
decine e decine di milioni
di cinesi, di indiani, nei prossimi anni?
A quali università si iscriveranno?
È una partita dalla quale
non si può restare fuori.
Io ho avuto la fortuna,
e la testardaggine,
di dirigere, ormai da dieci anni,
quello che oggi è il più avanzato
progetto di e-learning,
piattaforma di e-learning in Italia:
si chiama federica.eu.
"Federica" l'abbiamo chiamata così
perché ci piaceva l'idea
che quel signore con la barba,
che svariati secoli fa
fondò la Federico II, si chiamava così,
adesso si rivolgesse al mondo
con l'anima femminile,
più curiosa, più leggiadra, più viva,
che è appunto Federica.
Federica oggi è la principale
piattaforma in Italia.
E in Europa, se mettiamo
da fuori gli inglesi -
si sono messi fuori da loro,
perché poi hanno una cosa interessante,
poi ne parleremo -
ed è non solo importante
per i corsi che presenta,
e poi ne parleremo un attimo dopo,
ma è bellissima.
Perché noi abbiamo un'idea:
che qui in Italia siamo nel paese
più bello del mondo.
Siamo famosi in tutto
il mondo per il design,
e se stiamo ricostruendo le aule
in cui bisognerà studiare
per i prossimi decenni,
noi vogliamo che queste aule
siano bellissime.
Ed è quello che vi faccio
vedere adesso, un attimo insieme.
Rosetta is back, alla velocità della luce.
L'incontro tra le culture del mondo,
grazie ad internet è a portata di click.
Nell'universo del cyberspazio,
le aule sono senza confini.
Welcome to Federica:
l'università pubblica, gratis, a casa tua.
A tu per tu con i tuoi docenti:
Dante, nel 1300, ha scritto un testo
e ha parlato di argomenti, di problemi -
astrogalactic astronomy
is a very young science -
Distinguere tra le persone favorevoli
e quelle contrarie
all'oggetto che noi
stiamo studiando in quel momento -
Abbiamo esordito nella prima unità
dicendo che l'uovo degli uccelli,
come anche quello dei rettili,
è un uovo pleidoico.
È del tutto evidente
che a rischio di influenzare
l'opinione pubblica
attraverso la pubblicazione dei sondaggi,
ha venduto le associazioni di categoria -
la molla è rigida,
cioè per allungarla un po'
devo tirare molto forte -
la politica non è
soltanto un albero verde,
è qualcosa di più;
è qualche cosa a colori.
La politica è un technicolor,
come un tempo.
Dopo aver ascoltato i video,
sfoglia i testi delle lezioni.
Leggi con attenzione.
Puoi ripassare i video
mentre approfondisci gli argomenti.
L'ambiente didattico ideale
per la nuova generazione digitale.
La tua lezione in presa diretta.
Testi e video insieme, a tua disposizione.
Naviga nella straordinaria ricchezza
e varietà di risorse
selezionate dal tuo docente;
sottolinea i passaggi chiave,
mettili tra i tuoi appunti,
condividili con i tuoi compagni.
Tieni d'occhio i tuoi progressi.
Su federica, i MOOC
parlano finalmente italiano.
Il nuovo formato didattico,
che sta rivoluzionando
l'insegnamento universitario,
diventa un prodotto "Made in Italy"
grazie a un grande ateneo italiano
su una piattaforma italiana.
Con la cura del dettaglio,
e il senso del bello,
che il mondo riconosce all'Italia.
Unisciti a noi su federica, a tutto MOOC.
(Applausi)
Allora, questa è Federica.
Basta andare su Google,
scrivere federica.eu e ci trovate.
Se scrivete solo federica
trovate la piattaforma pre-MOOC,
dove ci sono comunque 300 corsi
ma senza il video.
E questa è l'evoluzione della specie:
sarebbe "federica sapiens",
o perlomeno "federica videns", se volete.
Perché il problema, vedete,
è tenere insieme queste due parti.
È tenere insieme la dinamica del video,
con la quale dobbiamo
comunque fare i conti
perché è più forte di noi.
Però, come vedrete, su federica
ci sono sempre i testi, a corredo.
Ci sono le fonti.
Io dico sempre:
noi non facciamo e-learning,
noi facciamo web learning.
Perché in rete c'è l'ira di Dio,
in rete c'è tutto!
Io la chiamo l'Alexandria Elettronica,
il sogno che abbiamo avuto per millenni.
Su ogni corso di federica
trovate almeno 150 link
a fonti autorevoli,
a libri - libri interi!
o le recensioni, o le biografie,
o altri video di approfondimento.
Insomma, un formato didattico
al passo con la nostra vita.
Federica è la piattaforma più importante
che c'è in Italia, di gran lunga,
grazie ai fondi europei
che l'hanno resa possibile:
si parla spesso male,
di questi fondi europei,
e non è vero.
Quando si ha un buon progetto,
arrivano i fondi;
e se si spendono bene -
Federica è fatto, soprattutto,
da donne giovani,
professioniste multimediali.
È un progetto d'avanguardia in Europa,
e sta crescendo molto rapidamente.
Non ci sono solo docenti
della Federico II:
ci sono docenti di altri atenei,
anche internazionali,
e stiamo moltiplicando l'offerta.
Noi ci auguriamo
che possa crescere sempre di più,
e ci sono le premesse
perché questo succeda.
Naturalmente, bisogna crederci in tanti.
E bisogna, come dire,
non lasciarsi colonizzare.
Perché il rischio è serio.
Nel momento in cui
le università americane,
con i numeri che vi ho detto,
entrano in campo,
il rischio che si vada tutti a Stanford
senza i 40.000 dollari
che ci vogliono adesso,
magari solo 4.000, c'è.
E visto che noi abbiamo, invece,
una straordinaria produzione
culturale in questo paese,
e visto che possiamo essere, noi,
attrattori anche dei giovani migliori.
Su federica, uno dei miei sogni
è di mettere insieme
tutti i vincitori di ERC,
che sono i progetti più competitivi.
Vincere un ERC junior
significa entrare di corsa
nella carriera universitaria.
Immaginatevi avere questi -
ce n'è uno, andatevelo a vedere;
il latino della pars orientis.
Quando si parlava latino -
per quattro secoli siamo stati noi
il bilinguismo del mondo.
E fatevi un giro:
ripeto, non ci si deve nemmeno iscrivere
per vedersi il trailer e la prima lezione.
L'iscrizione è comunque gratuita,
e ci fa piacere se la fate
perché così entriamo in contatto con voi.
Ci mandate i feedback, le critiche:
guardatevi il corso
di sociologia della povertà,
è bellissimo.
Oppure, robotics foundation:
è uno dei massimi esperti internazionali.
Oppure, se vi interessa la politica,
vi consiglio "Politique globale",
anche perché il docente,
che lo insegna in francese
sottotitolato in inglese,
è meglio di Clooney,
dal punto di vista della capacità scenica.
E anche questo, come si dice, aiuta.
Questo video lo trovate nella home page.
Nella home page di federica.eu
ci sono anche quattro sezioni di blog
per coloro che vogliono capire
cosa sta succedendo,
perché sta succedendo di tutto.
Ed è straordinaria l'opportunità
che si sta aprendo per tutti noi.
E in un paese come l'Italia,
dove tre settimane fa,
sul Corriere della Sera,
due pagine di Federico Fubini
ci hanno spiegato che siamo diventati
il fanalino di coda dell'Europa.
Nella classe d'età 25 - 34,
siamo al 24 percento di laureati:
la media UE è 33 percento;
Francia, Spagna e Polonia sono al 46.
È una vergogna.
Questo è un paese che si sta
condannando all'eutanasia!
Ma scusate, ma dove saremo fra 20 anni,
con questi tassi di istruzione terziaria?
Allora, se si può - e si può - rispondere,
non mettendoci a costruire
università di serie C
in giro per il paese,
che ci vogliono dieci anni
per accontentare 100 baroni,
ma con la migliore cultura
accademica internazionale,
dico io: facciamolo.
Ma soprattutto, dico: si può.
Si può, veramente, fare.
Welcome to Federica.
Grazie.
(Applausi)